>>man: Well, welcome everyone to another great
AuthorsGoogle session. We have the amazing
honor and privilege to have here at Google
once again, Condoleezza Rice. You folks may
have been at her, the great talk that we had
a couple years ago when Secretary of State,
she was here with Foreign Secretary, David
Miliband, from the UK. And we had a great
session then. And we're here to talk this
time about her book. Obviously, she needs
very little introduction from me, but we really
would love to get in to her; have her talk
about her new book, which is really, really
fascinating in terms of her upbringing in
Alabama. We were talking before the show here
and before the session. I actually have a
fairly personal connection. It turns out we
have some to-do items after the fact here
because, if you've read any of the book, you'll
discover that Secretary Rice's maternal grandfather's
name was Albert Ray, was from Alabama, outside
of Birmingham. Turns out my maternal grandfather's
name was Edward Ray, also from outside of
Birmingham, Alabama and my mother was born
right outside of Birmingham. So, we're thinking
there's some connection--
>>Rice: Some connection there.
>>man: So if I call her cousin in the middle
of the session--
[laughter]
you will, you will know why. So, I think what
we're gonna try to do is, through a Q&A format,
try to talk a little bit about the book and
what's going on, Stanford football--
>>Rice: Yeah.
>>man: those kinds of things.
[laughter]
And then have some time for you all to ask
some questions, too. So, the first thing I
wanted to ask was, obviously in the book,
you talk a lot about your childhood in Birmingham
and you described it as the most segregated
city in all of America in the 50s and 60s.
So, can you share with us a little bit? I
know this is in the book, but can you share
with us a little bit about your experiences
with segregation and how that affected your
aspirations growing up?
>>Rice: Absolutely. Well, first of all, thanks
for having me here. It's great to be here
and I can only tell this story by saying first
of all that I was born in 1954, in Birmingham,
Alabama. Now, before you start counting, that
makes me 55; 56 next month.
[laughter]
And Birmingham in 1954 was really two very
separate societies. On the one hand, I grew
up in black middle-class Birmingham; a little
conclave in Birmingham called Titusville,
and we had, in our schools we had instrumental
band. I had piano lessons, ballet lessons.
My parents, in many ways, were, as I have
said in the book, ordinary people. My mom
was a school teacher, an English teacher.
She actually taught, as one of her first students,
Willie Mays, and he said that she told him,
"Son, you're gonna be a ball player and if
you need to leave class a little bit early,
you go right ahead." So, he appreciates that.
[laughter]
My mom also was a musician; quite elegant
lady who believed in the democracy of the
arts and so in her very tough neighborhood
high school, introduced operettas and fine
music. My dad was a high school guidance counselor,
Presbyterian minister; later on a University
administrator. His domain was sports. I was
supposed to be an all American linebacker
named "John"--
[laughter]
and he had bought John's football and much
to his surprise he had a daughter. But he
was a big and imposing man and very interested
in politics and history. But they were in
that way ordinary people, but they were also
extraordinary for the times in which they
lived and in Birmingham, it really was very
separate society. She couldn't go to a restaurant,
you couldn't go to a movie theatre. I did
not have a white classmate until we moved
to Denver when I was 12. It was completely
segregated. Most of the time because my little
enclave was one where the kids were very much
the center of attention and taken care of,
segregation didn't intrude every day. You
lived in this little separate cocoon, but
occasionally, you had to meet the outside
world and I tell a couple of those stories.
For instance, going to see Santa Claus when
I was five years old. And you know what the
drill is; you go to the department store,
you stand in line, Santa Claus puts you on
his knees, says "What do you want for Christmas?"
Well, my parents were watching this particular
Santa Claus take the little black kids and
stand them out here and take the little white
kids and put them on his knee. And my father,
I overheard my father say to my mother, "Angelina,
if he does that to Condoleezza, I'm gonna
pull all that stuff off of him and show him
to be the cracker that he is."
[laughter]
And, as you might imagine, little five year
old Condie goes ahead with a kind of trepidation.
Ok, Santa Claus, Daddy, Santa Claus, Daddy.
[laughter]
But Santa Claus must have felt my father's
size because he pulled me on his knee and
said, "Little girl, what would you like for
Christmas?" So, all's well that ends well,
but it shows how racially charged Birmingham
could be and so that's the community I grew
up in.
>>man: Right. Now, so, despite the segregation
and discrimination, you've also said in the
book that this community was a place where
you had them convinced that you could be President
of the United States.
>>Rice: Absolutely. You couldn't have a hamburger
at Woolworth's lunch counter, but you could
be President of the United States if you wanted
to be. And it wasn't just me, it was really
the entire community where teachers were the
most important people in the community, where
principal's of schools were giants in the
community. One of the principals there was
a man named R. C. Johnson, who was the principal
of Parker High School, the largest black school
in Birmingham. He was the father of Alma Johnson
Powell, who is Colin Powell's wife. And this
community told you there are no victims. There
are no excuses. You are gonna have to be twice
as good and it was, by the way, not said as
a matter for debate, it was said as a fact.
And I think that way, instilled in us this
sense that if we were educated, it was gonna
be transforming. It was armor against racism,
even if "they" meaning the white man--
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: didn't like you, "they" would have
to respect you and that's how I grew up.
>>man: And so you did lots of things besides
school. You did skating; you wanted to be
a figure skater.
>>Rice: Oh. I wanted to be a figure skater.
Yes, piano lessons.
>>man: Piano lessons and you still perform,
I understand--not as much.
>>Rice: Well, piano is actually an interesting
story because I studied piano from age three.
My grandmother taught piano lessons. I took
piano lessons with her. I was gonna be a great
concert pianist. I went off to college; majored
in music for two years and then went to the
Aspen Music Festival School where I met 12
year olds who could play from sight, everything
that had taken me all year to learn. I thought,
"I'm about to end up teaching 13 years olds
to murder Beethoven for a living, or maybe
I'm gonna play at Nordstrom, but I'm not gonna
play Carnegie Hall."
[laughter]
I went back and I had one of those uncomfortable
conversations with my parents, you know, "Mom
and Dad, I'm changing my major." "What are
you changing your major to, dear?" "I don't
know." "What do want to do with your life?"
"Well, after all, it's my life." "Well, after
all, it's our money. Find a major."
[laughter]
And, fortunately for me, I wandered into a
course in International Politics, taught by
a Soviet specialist and his name was Joseph
Korbel. He was Madeleine Albright's father.
And Joseph Korbel opened up this incredible
world to me of things international, things
Russian, and I knew what I wanted to do. I
wanted to be a Soviet specialist and luckily
for me, when I went home and said, "Gee, Mom
and Dad. I found it. I wanna be a Soviet specialist."
[man laughs]
They didn't say what's a nice, black girl
from Birmingham, Alabama--
[laughter]
talking about being a Soviet specialist? They
said, "Go for it," and that's how I got into
the field.
>>man: Right. But yet, you're memoir at least,
so, hopefully this means there's perhaps a
part two? Because your--
>>Rice: Yes.
>>man: your memoir is focused on your childhood
and your upbringing--
>>Rice: That's right. That's right.
>>man: so, can we expect a part two about
your career and--
>>Rice: Well, yes, as I was leaving government
I had to decide what I was gonna write and
I will, everybody writes the obligatory Secretary
of State's eight year memoir--
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: and I will write that memoir--
[man laughs]
and, in fact, writing it now. But, I'm very
often asked how did you become who you are?
>>man: Yeah.
>>Rice: And I felt that people had to know
John and Angelina Rice in order to answer
that question. And I wanted to do this as
a book that shows how important good parents
are, how important good community is, how
important focus on education and values can
be and how even in the extraordinary circumstances
of segregated Birmingham, this little community
raised extraordinary kids.
>>man: Mm-hmm.
>>Rice: I'm not, by the way, even the first
PhD in my family. My grandfather managed to
get a college education. My aunt, my father's
sister, was a professor of Victorian literature
of all things. She wrote books on Dickens.
[man laughs]
And the in my community, the first black woman
governor of the International Monetary Fund,
the man who is currently the President of
the University of Maryland, Baltimore, the
man who is currently President of the University
in Missouri, Kansas City, two Pulitzer Prize
winners, but that little community, thanks
to the way that this community dealt with
its kids; very accomplished.
>>man: Right. Well, I wanted to ask you a
couple of other questions about race. Sometimes,
we get a tendency to hear people talk about
an authentic black experience.
>>Rice: Yeah, yeah.
>>man: And oftentimes, sometimes it's equated
with what your political views happen to be.
>>Rice: Right.
>>man: And it's no mystery to most people
that you've had political views that are not
necessarily the same as the vast majority
of, at least expressed, in the ballot box.
>>Rice: Yeah.
>>man: The majority of other black Americans.
How do you, when someone says, "Well, she's
a Republican, so how can--
>>Rice: Right.
>>man: she's not really black."
>>Rice: Yeah. Right.
>>man: How do you deal with that?
[laughter]
>>Rice: Well, the first thing I tell people
is I don't need anybody to tell me how to
be black.
[laughter]
I've been black all my life; I know how to
do that, right? And, in fact, the unfortunate
thing is that it doesn't just relate to being
a Republican. That's fine and I can explain
to you why I'm a Republican; came from foreign
policy initially and didn't care much for
Jimmy Carter's response to the invasion of
Afghanistan by boycotting the Olympics. I
thought surely the United States can do better
than that.
>>man: Mm-hmm.
>>Rice: And I voted for Ronald Reagan, but
my views are eclectic political views. I say
in the book I favor affirmative action. I'm
also a fierce defender of the second Amendment.
So, my views are all over the place as I think
most Americans view are--
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: and I think we get very much putting
people into little boxes, but it is also the
case, unfortunately, that this stuff about
authentically black, which I have no idea
what that's supposed to mean, has begun to
translate into, "Well, you're not authentically
black if you study hard," and "You're not
authentically black if maybe you major in
engineering." That's shooting yourself in
the head.
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: To me, authentically black meant black
Birmingham was going to achieve at a level
that white America couldn't ignore it.
>>man: Mm-hmm.
>>Rice: And I think that's the most authentically
black that I can possibly express.
>>man: Absolutely. Well, one of the questions
in the book you talk about your view of the
term "African American."
>>Rice: Yeah.
>>man: So, can you explain a little bit how
you see that term that's so frequently used?
>>Rice: Yes. I don't actually like this term,
"African American." I prefer black and I'll
tell you why. I think that African American
mimics an immigration narrative that is actually
not the black narrative. Europeans and Africans
came to this country together; Africans in
chains.
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: And we built this country together,
not because Africans came here by choice,
but because Africans were forced to come here.
We also have all kinds of crazy, intertwined
genes in the American gene pool and I fear,
I understand why it was done. It was meant
to make a connection to Africa, but I fear
that it actually lets us off the hook for
dealing with, first of all, the birth defect
of slavery and all of that mess. Secondly,
dealing with the fact that the immigration
narrative, there is one black immigration
narrative; West Indians who came here, like
Colin Powell's parents.
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: But for the children of the Confederacy,
the children of Dixie, I like black and white.
That's about as clear as it can get--
[man laughs]
that this was a country built by forced labor
of African slaves.
>>man: Right, right. Well, another question
about the book. So, you wanted to target it
to young adults.
>>Rice: Yes.
>>man: Well, another question about the book.
You wanted to target it to young adults.
>>Rice: Yes.
>man: And so I wanted you to talk a little
bit about that and some of the lessons that
you're hoping to convey.
>>Rice: Well, I'm hoping to convey to young
adults that really, my story shows that just
about anything is possible. There is no earthly
reason that a little girl who grew up in Birmingham,
Alabama under those circumstances should have
ended up as Secretary of State of the United
States of America and certainly getting there
by the circuitous path of being a Soviet specialist.
And so, I try to say to young adults, "Don't
let anybody define what it is you want to
be by looking at you and saying,' Oh, well
you shouldn't be interested in those things.'"
I mean, my passion was something that really
was pretty odd for a black kid from Birmingham,
but it just happened to be my passion and
because it was my passion, I was actually
good at it and that led to a whole set of
outcomes. The other thing is to say what my
parents believed fervently, "You may not be
able to control your circumstances, but you
can control your reaction to your circumstances."
>>man: Right, right.
>>Rice: And if you see yourself as a victim
of something, then you're gonna feel aggrieved
and the other half of the coin of aggrievement
is actually entitlement. Now, they owe me
this and they owe me that. And that is a dead
end in a society that doesn't reward aggreviement.
>>man: Yeah. So last week you were, you met
with President Obama--
>>Rice: I did.
>>man: in the Oval Office and I assume you
gave him a copy of the book.
>>Rice: I did. I gave him a copy of that book
and a copy of the young adult version for
Malia and Sasha.
>>man: Right, excellent.
[laughter]
So was this the first time you've been there
since?
>>Rice: I've been to the White House, but
not to see the President.
>>man: See the President?
[laughter]
So, you--
>>Rice: No, I mean, I've been to the White
House since the Obama Administration.
[laughter]
>>man: Understood. So we have to ask you:
did you talk about foreign policy a little
bit?
>>Rice: Ahh, yeah. We did.
>>man: Ok. So--
[laughter]
in any of the counsel, the sage counsel that
you can tell us about?
>>Rice: Actually, one thing that may be worth
noting is it's not that unusual for the sitting
President to invite back--
>man: Sure.
>>Rice: cabinet, a former cabinet office,
particularly foreign policy because despite
all of our twists and turns and doing things
a little bit differently, there really is
a lot of continuity in American foreign policy
and it's awfully important that people in
the world understand that it's bipartisan.
>>man: Mm-hmm.
>>Rice: And so President Bush would, from
time to time, have former cabinet officials
back. So the President and I had a chance
to cover the waterfront and talk a whole variety
of things and I had known him before because
when I was Secretary of State, he was on the
Foreign Relations Committee of the Senate,
which oversaw the State Department. And so,
we've gotten to know each other before.
>>man: Right, great. So, in terms of foreign
policies these days, I mean, what, how are
you thinking about it? Are you currently optimistic
about the American foreign policy in the state
of the world, or pessimistic and how do you
think about it?
>>Rice: Well, in the long run I'm optimistic.
First of all, just because I'm an optimist
to begin with, but also because I've seen
the United States go through bad times and
come out where what seemed impossible later
on seems inevitable. I used to always remind
myself, when I was Secretary, that today's
headlines and history's judgments are rarely
the same. And I would keep portraits of Secretary's
of State near me to remind me of that; Thomas
Jefferson, first Secretary, everybody kept
him, George Marshall, probably the greatest
Secretary, everybody kept him, but I kept
Dean Acheson who, when he left, was remembered
for who lost China; doesn't, not now. And
I kept William Seward; he bought Alaska.
>>man: Mm-hmm.
>>Rice: When he bought Alaska, you wanna talk
about rough congressional hearings, how could
you have spent seven million dollars on that
ice box to the Czar of Russia? And several
years later I was talking to the man who became,
who was the Defense Minister of Russia, Sergei
Ivanov, he said, "You know, Condy, I went
to Alaska. It is so beautiful. It reminds
me of Russia."
[man laughs]
Sergei used to be in Russia. So we have to
remember today's headlines, history's judgment
are never the same. And so saying that, I
think we've got some big challenges; big challenge
in Afghanistan and Pakistan. But I think we
will get it right if we're patient with the
fact that Afghanistan was the fifth poorest,
is the fifth poorest country in the world.
It was always gonna be tough.
>>man: Right.
>>Rice: I think we're making progress on the
Iranian problem because the Iranian regime
is inherently weak, particularly after what
happened to it in June of 2009. The sanctions
are biting on an economy that is very weak.
I think there are new challenges on the horizon,
like Mexico. The border with Mexico is beginning
to resemble a failed state, where the Mexican
police can't be trusted and the Mexican army
is outgunned by the drug cartels. That's really
dangerous. And I'll tell you, in 1996, I went
with the Stanford football team to the Sun
Bowl in El Paso, I was provost, and we held
the big banquet across the border in Juarez.
I went to the Sun Bowl this past year with
Stanford. Nobody went anywhere near Juarez
and in that period of time, that border has
become exceedingly dangerous. So we have some
new challenges, but I think we'll come through
them.
>>man: Ok. Great. Well, in a moment I wanna
open it up for some of your questions. There
was one Google related question I had to ask
you--
>>Rice: Yes, yes, yes.
>>man: when I had the opportunity, but last
time you were here, we talked a fair bit about
something that's really important to us here
at Google, which is Internet freedom; free
expression on the Internet and while you were
Secretary, you actually did a lot of work
in that area--
>>Rice: Yes.
>>man: and really advanced the ball forward.
How do you, I know you have some really great
thoughts about this--
>>Rice: Yes.
>>man: how do you see this going and what
would you counsel a company like Google, who
cares deeply about this, what would you counsel
us to do? To do with government, instead,
to deal with this?
>>Rice: Well, let me take the big one; the
elephant in the room is China.
>>man: Yeah, there you go.
>>Rice: And when people say to me, "When will
China surpass the United States as the most
important global economy and political player?"
I say one thing, "Can you imagine that a country
that is as terrified of the Internet, that
is hacking into people's servers and trying
to find that last human rights advocate, is
that country gonna lead the knowledge based
revolution?" No. And so you have, with the
Internet, in countries particularly like China,
this clash between something that is democratizing,
something that is information giving, something
that allows people to remotely organize themselves
and the authoritarians need to control all
of those. My view is that, and I understand
short term issues, like today's earnings or
the quarterly earnings, I used to be a corporate
director. But I also know that an enlightened
long-term view says that is these countries,
these authoritarians, don't come to terms
with the aspirations of their people and allow
more freedom of expression, it's not gonna
be very stable. And you're not gonna be doing
business in China anyway because if China
goes the wrong direction, we're going to be
looking at an even more closed and even more
authoritarian place where foreign business's
will be shut out, where IPR will be protected
even less than it is now. And so, it seems
to me that the long term view is to do what
you can to enhance the capacity of citizens
in these countries to use the power of the
Internet.
>>man: Great. Well, let's open it up to some
of your questions. We have a first one, right?
Right away, sir.
>>audience male #1: You're regards about your
experience about being required to be twice
as good is related a lot with our experiences
of growing as Jewish children in Russia.
>>Rice: Yes.
>>audience male #1: In this respect, I wanted
to ask you in as students persue the Russian
studies at Stanford and what do you tell your
students in general, what is your focus at
Stanford?
>>Rice: Yes, thank you. Well, my focus at
Stanford, I'm teaching for the Business School
and I'm teaching a course called The Global
Context, which basically says, "Remember that
governments are the principle architects of
the environment in which you will be." I then
teach undergraduates; a course called Challenges
and Dilemmas in US Foreign Policy, but it
won't surprise you that given my long association
with things Russian, I continue to teach about
Russia in both of those courses. And what
I say is that I think Russia, which went through
a very difficult period of time in the 90s,
leading to the late 90s, the rise of Vladimir
Putin, the rise of a more authoritarian instinct
is actually now, there's a kind of battle
going on in Russia. On the one hand, you have
those who want to continue to take Russia's
power and might on the basis of extractive
industries, oil-based economies, where the
economy is great if the price of oil is 140
dollars a barrel and not so great if it's
70. Where it's authoritarian, where it's external
manifestation is more like "empire" and there
are those who are saying, "Well, you know,
that isn't where Russia should be. Russia
should be leading the global knowledge revolution."
President Medvedev has said several times,
"Russia has the best software engineers in
the world." And I always thought to myself,
"Yes, and they're all working in the United
States and Israel."
[laughter]
And that's the problem. And to the degree
that Russia can mobilize it's human potential
toward a more open, creative society; to take
advantage of all that creativity, we're all
gonna be better off. And so yes, I continue
to follow Russian affairs and I actually think
where Russia ends up in this is very important
to international peace and stability.
>>audience male#1: Thanks a lot.
>>Rice: Thank you.
>>man: Go ahead, sir.
>audience male #2: Hi, thanks for coming.
I wanted to ask you a question along the lines
of how can we all get along. The politics
today is so, it seems counterproductive and
I don't know, I view you as somebody who could
actually make a difference there.
>>Rice: Thank you.
>>audience male #2: What could you or other
people do to take a leadership role in making
things more productive?
>>Rice: Right. And I agree with you. To be
fair, our politics have always been a little
rough in the United States. I mean, Thomas
Jefferson leaked a letter saying George Washington
was senile because he thought Washington was
too close to Alexander Hamilton. I mean, our
politics have always been a little rough.
[laughter]
But I think that the pace of our politics
now, driven by 24 hour news cycles and cable
television, which I listen to like everybody
else, but can you even tell what people are
saying anymore? They're so busy yelling at
each other; nobody stops to listen. And in
a political system, like the United States,
where the founding fathers separated power
between the branches of government, you need
time. You need time for people not to have
to go to their corners and have a mic shoved
in front of their faces the minute a problem
comes up. They commit to a particular solution
and now they're stuck. And if they move toward
the other side, they're considered to be flip-flopping
or they're considered to be wavering or they're
not principled enough. Politics really is
like sausage-making. It's tough. It's not
that you abandon your principles, but I can
assure you, I write in the book about the
Civil Rights Legislation of 1964 and 1965,
which actually allowed me to go to a restaurant
for the first time. That would never have
happened with cable television because Lyndon
Johnson would not have been able to put together
that coalition of northern Republicans and
Texans and others to put them together and
overcome this extremely difficult issue. So,
here's my prescription: let's turn down the
volume. Let's just turn down the volume and
stop yelling at each other and accusing each
other. Let's recognize that we have some very
crucial problems in the United States. But
we know some of the elements of how to solve
them. We know that private sector led growth
is important or we're not gonna have jobs.
We know that fiscal discipline is important
or we're not gonna have investors. We know
that immigration is important to our country
because it keeps us from the tragic demographics
of Russia and the sclerotic demographics of
Europe. And I don't understand don't believe
this is my country when I hear people say
we ought to deny citizenship to the children
of illegal immigrants who were born here.
I don't recognize that kind of country. Let's
all agree that we need free trade so that
exports can grow and let's all agree that
the K-12 education system is a crime when
I can look at your zip code and know whether
you're gonna get a good job. And then let's
work from those basic principles. I think
if actually we could re-focus on some of those
principles and turn down the volume some;
maybe we can get back to the place where we
have workable politics. Thank you.
>>audience member #2: Thanks.
>>man: Great. Next question.
>>audience male #3: I have a question about
day's past. Back when the United States decided
to go to Iraq, you went to Russia and discussed
at length why it is a good idea to go to Iraq
and you spent quite a while behind closed
doors with then President Putin. What did
you discuss?
[laughter]
>>Rice: Well, that I will talk about. I think
that, let me say one thing about Russia and
President Putin. Things got difficult toward
the end, but in global affairs, for the most
part, we have a very good cooperation with
Russia, on the Middle East, on North Korea,
on the War on Terrorism; very good cooperation,
on Afghanistan. We had trouble with Russia
when we got involved in what Russia considered
to be its periphery; Georgia, Central Asia,
Ukraine and the states of the Warsaw Pact
like Poland and the Czech Republic. But on
Iraq, I have to give President Putin credit.
He, they voted for resolution 1441, which
was a resolution that said Saddam had to open
up his WMD sites or face serious consequences.
But Putin told us "I cannot agree to a resolution
that will take us to war." And he said it
from the very beginning. All that you can
ask of another leader is that they tell you
from the very beginning what they can do and
what they can't do. There were some leaders
who said, "Oh, yes, we'll be with you." And
then when things got tough, they weren't there.
I didn't respect that. I do respect when people
tell you what they can do and what they can't
do. We did not have a disagreement with Russia
about Saddam's weapons of mass destruction.
They thought he had them, too. He did have
capability and infrastructure. What he didn't
have was stock piles. But we disagreed with
Russia about what that meant in terms of what
needed to be done in Iraq. But I will say
also about Russia that once the war was over,
Russia quite quickly became part of the solution,
not part of the problem. Now, one reason that
Russia did that is if they were very clear
that they wanted their oil and gas contracts
to be honored by the new Iraqi government
and I always felt that Russia's economic interests
were more important here to Russia than almost
anything else.
>>audience member #3: Thank you very much.
>>Rice: You're welcome.
>>man: Ok. Next question.
>>audience member #4: Yeah, I guess to help
us get past caricatures and stereotypes of
foreign figureheads, can you elaborate on
some of your closest personal relationships?
Some of your best friends, anything, conflicts,--
>>Rice: Yes.
>>audience male #4: and maybe talk about people
that struck you as either impressive or who
had areas for improvement?
>>Rice: Yes.
[laughter]
The person that I think of, there's several
that I, Tony Blair. Not only was he kind of
a rock star and that was clear, but he also
was somebody of real principle. When he said
he was gonna do something he did it. I think
that he believed, fundamentally, in the proposition
that no man, woman or child should live in
tyranny. And that brought us close to him.
And I have enormous admiration for him. Also,
what he did in Middle East as the Cortez envoy
for the Middle East was quite impressive.
Ariel Sharon, who was a tough, little tank
driver and was somebody who nobody would have
thought to be interested in peace because
he was brought to power to defeat the Palestinian
Resistance, but by 2003, he had taken a whole
part of the Israeli political spectrum and
put it in support of a two-state solution.
And I think he may, ultimately, be one of
the reasons we will get to a Palestinian state.
I quite admire Angela Merkel, who I think
is, as German Chancellor, maybe in the most
important position in Europe right now. The
European Union is going through some very
difficult times. When you have German newspapers
that suggest that the Greeks sell the Acropolis
to pay their debt, we have a problem--
[laughter]
of European unity. And Angela Merkel is trying
to steer this course where the German taxpayer
no longer wants to pay for proliferigate spending
in the rest of Europe and she wants to hold
the European Union together. And I think she's
done a remarkable job. Ellen Sirleaf Johnson,
the President of Liberia.
>>man: Mmhmm
>>Rice:Ellen Johnson Sirleaf, the President
of Liberia, a country that was on the front
pages of The New York Times in 2003 with 13
year old boys with AK-47s running the streets.
Where the United States sent a hundred marines
in to stabilize the ports in the airport and
that country now has a chance. It's desperately
poor. Twenty five years of civil war, but
I will never forget one of the most remarkable
moments; we went, Laura Bush and I, went to
her Inaugural and she was giving her speech
and all the African Heads of State were there
and all of a sudden she said, "And today,
every member of my cabinet, and I personally,
will publish our personal finances." And all
these African leaders who had been cheering
everything she said, this didn't sound like
such a great idea.
[laughter]
And I thought, "She's changing the whole face
of Africa by what she's saying here." So,
those are some of the people that I admire
most. Probably the oddest that I met was Muammar
al-Gaddafi.
[laughter]
I was the first Secretary of State to go to,
and Coby's laughing because he was the advance
on that trip, but when Gaddafi said that he
wanted me to meet him in his tent--
[laughter]
we decided we didn't know what that meant,
but it didn't sound very good.
[laughter]
And so, but it was quite something. He's actually
more rational to have a conversation with
than you might imagine.
>>audience member #4: Thank you.
>>man: Ok, we've got about five more minutes
for questions, so let's keep them coming.
>>audience member #5: I found it fascinating
just all these connections you had with kids
you grew up with that came from Birmingham
and it seems like, especially impressive given
that underprivileged environment, but it seems
like one factor you had was this extreme privilege
of engaged parents. And it seems like that's
not, and I think that's something that's shared
here in this room by a lot of people, how
do you, it's not really something that I think
is focused on enough in education today. What
are your thoughts on I guess that and how
can that, how can your experience be a model
for that type of--
>>Rice: Absolutely. I think you're exactly
right. You've gotten, you've broken the code.
It is engaged parents, but if you don't have
engaged parents, you'd better have an engaged
adult with every child. And whether it's the
Boys and Girls Clubs of America, where I'm
on the national board, I think they do a fine
job of engagement with the kids, particularly
from underprivileged environments, whether
it's a teacher that takes an interest in those
kids, a pastor or the community, every child
has got to have some adult that says, "Here's
how you navigate to get to be successful."
And it is just, we can't just leave it on
the schools to do it all. Some adult has got
to be engaged with every child.
>>audience member #5: Do you think parents
themselves are aware enough?
>>Rice: I do think parents, you know one of
the things that I did when I came back here
the last time, was I formed something called
The Center for a New Generation. There are
now five of them in East Palo Alto, Redwood
City, East Menlo, and they're an after school
enrichment program for kids from that region,
that part of the state and you know that's
a very impoverished part of the state. But
the idea that their parents didn't care was
just exploded. These parents were just trying
to get their kids into the center. So, sometimes
I think parents don't have the means, they
don't have the right language, they don't
know how to access the school system, but
they care. And whenever we had a performance
at The Center for a New Generation with the
school band, I mean the instrumental band
and so forth, those parents were there taking
pictures and being proud of their kids. So,
I think there's a lot to work with.
>>audience member #5: Thank you.
>>Rice: Thank you.
>>audience member #6: All right. So, we touched
briefly upon race relations because obviously,
you contribute a large portion of that in
your book and as well to political friction
in the country. There are a number of, or
there is a current that believes that race
relations are starting to rear their head
again in politics and the NAACP just put out
a paper called Tea Party Nationalism.
>>Rice: Yeah.
>>audience member #6: About the radical right
and racism in the Tea Party movement and the
up rise of that. What are your thoughts as
a black conservative on the Tea Party and
these unsavory aspects of it?
>>Rice: Right, right. Well, there are unsavory
aspects to a lot of movements, right? There
are extremists in a lot of movements. I think
on balance the tea party is a grassroots movement
of folks who don't like where their country
is going and they're trying to express that.
And sometimes they express it in ways that
I don't agree, like on immigration or on free
trade, but sometimes they express it in a
way with which I completely agree; that the
conversation in Washington and the conversation
in the rest of the country is not the same
conversation. And I think they're trying to
get Washington's attention that people out
here are worried about having gone to college,
majored in Accounting cause they wanted to
be English majors, but they had to find a
job, buying a home, as David Brooks said recently,
buying a home they actually could afford and
now they find the equity is half of it. I
think that's what these people are expressing.
And we don't do any good by branding them
with a kind of broad brush. Yes, I think there
are some people who've expressed racist views,
but frankly, I didn't like it very much when
people said George Bush was a racist because
of Katrina. Suddenly, he was a racist because
a hurricane hit one of the poorest parts of
America in New Orleans? This is a term we
need to stop throwing around because given
our deep wounds as a country, the worst and
most incendiary thing that you can do is call
somebody else a racist. And you better be
sure that that's actually what's going on
rather than you just have a political disagreement.
And so, I would tell people in the Tea Party
stop saying those things and I would tell
people in NAACP stop saying those things.
And let's focus on the problems that we share
jointly because America is an extraordinary
place where two black Secretaries of State,
a black President of the United States and
with the heritage and history that we have
that means we've come a very long way. So,
while I fully understand that there are elements
of many movements that I don't agree with
and that there's racism in some of them, it's
really something that we ought to step back
from. And I said turn down the volume, well;
this is one where we really better turn down
the volume because we will actually empower
the most extreme elements of our society if
we're constantly pointing to, pointing to
them and giving them a megaphone.
>>audience member #6: Thank you.
>>Rice: Yeah.
>>man: Let's try to get the last two questions
over here.
>>Rice: Sure.
>>audience member #7: So, from the outside
looking in, it seems like there's a schism
between government and policy and technology,
at least in the US. Which seems interesting
because at Google, we're in the business of
changing the world and essentially, so are
you. So, how do you think, ideally, we could
bridge that gap between the technologies we're
developing here and what policy makers are
trying to do from an implementation or an
efficiency standpoint?
>>Rice: Yeah. I'll give you two examples where
I think a lot of work could be done and some
work is being done. Technology may actually
help with the school problem that I was talking
about because I would rather have the very,
very, very best teacher in every classroom
and we outta strive for that, but sometimes
you have to make up for teaching that may
not be optimum and technology is a way to
do it. And so, I think technology and K-12
education and improvement of K-12 education
is something where we can bridge some of the
policy problems we have and what the technology
can offer. And the other big one is in democratization.
There is no doubt in my mind that the fact
that people can get on the Internet, and by
the way, a lot of my Chinese students and
friends tell me they can try and block, they
can try and filter, we'll always find a way
around it. And so, it is having a democratizing
effect. We saw the effect of it in Iran where
the regime just couldn't shut down all of
the technological outlets and I think if we're
more conscious about it, I thought Hilary
Clinton, Secretary Clinton, gave a very good
speech about this and I think these are things
that could be followed up on. Now, I'm not
asking companies to become either part of
the policy process or to become social entrepreneurs.
I'm just saying that for all of us, for the
long term benefit to all of us, for our long
term interest, for technology to play a role
in the betterment of K-12 education and in
democratization around the world is gonna
benefit both policy and the technology sector.
>>audience member #7: Thank you.
>>man: Great. Last question.
>>audience member #8: Dr. Rice, thank you
for coming to speak with us today. This is,
I'm too short for this. In your book, you
write, you mention several times about how
much books have shaped the way you think today.
You write that one of your proudest moments
was when your father gave your grandfather's
books to you and Auntie Teresa read some of
her books 25 times. And I wanted to ask you,
what are some of the books from your childhood
that you really cherished?
>>Rice: Yes, well thank you. Boy, you really
read the book; that's great.
[laughter]
Well, I tended, as a child not to be the voracious
reader that my parents were; that they wanted
me to be. So, they tried a lot of things,
you know, classic comics and all kinds of
things. And then they realized that I discovered
and loved biography. And it started with the
biographies of the Founding--of the great
composers. So, Mozart's biography, I wanted
to be Constance Mozart. Most little girls
had a crush on Elvis; I had a crush on Mozart.
[laughter]
I, my parents gave me all these books about
the composers. As I went through life, it
has been biography that has been most stimulating
for me. I read, during 2006, the lives of
the Founding Fathers, a series of really great
biographies: Jefferson, Hamilton, Madison,
Franklin. And it really convinced me of this
belief that I have that what seems impossible
one day later on seems inevitable because
when you read their biographies; there is
no earthy reason the United States of America
should have ever come into being. With a third
of George Washington's troops down to smallpox,
taking on the greatest military power of the
time, and so, I loved those biographies. I've
gone on to read a wonderful biography of Teddy
Roosevelt, which is kind of the opening of
the frontier of the United States. And I've
read a couple of really excellent biographies
recently of Joseph Stalin, which, I think,
has given me new insights to Russia. So, I
find through people's lives and people's experiences
that not only does history open up to me in
a way that it doesn't if I just read the history,
but the lessons of the triumph of the human
spirit, both for good and for evil, opens
up to me. And so, I continue to be a dedicated
biography reader and maybe one reason that
I wanted to write this book, which is a kind
of autobiography, although it's really my
parents story, is that I think we learn more
through the vibrancy of people's lives than
in any other way.
>>man: Well, speaking of biography, we wanted
to have a chance for a book signing. I think
you'll be available for awhile longer--
>>Rice: I will be, that's right.
>>man: to do that. I encourage all of you,
if you haven't picked up a copy of the book
to do so. But we're just really, really thrilled
to have you here again, Dr. Rice and thank
you so much for coming.
>>Rice: Thank you. Thank you and thanks for
a great conversation.
[applause]